all right let's get into Friday feedback
so many different messages coming in
continuing for all sorts of different
reasons and I want to have an
opportunity here to go over some stuff
with people in the audience one of the
things that I love about my audience is
you all don't forget about gun safety
just because it's been like a little
while since the last major mass shooting
now in the United States we have
individual shootings
we have mass shootings and then we have
major mass shootings major means like it
actually makes National headlines it's a
crazy country where we actually have
mass shootings every day but most of
them don't make National headlines okay
you all keep your eye on the ball even
when there hasn't been a major national
mass shooting for a little bit
here's a very interesting uh YouTube
comment which says David as a
law-abiding citizen who owns several
firearms that I use for sport shooting
and hunting there's something no one has
been able to explain to me how is it
that the Federal Government Can
Implement and enforce a national ban on
fully automatic weapons and shot off
shotguns but is unable to do the same
for semi-automatic Firearms seems to me
that every mass shooting in recent
history has involved a semi-automatic
firearm a ban on semi-automatic Firearms
would not violate the Second Amendment
and as a matter of fact could we argued
that it speaks directly to the
well-regulated militia aspect of the
Second Amendment what are your thoughts
well the answer is of course you could
ban semi-automatic weapons but there
isn't Congressional support to do it
this I'm not going to pretend that I can
cite every law on which the current
status quo is based okay that that I'm
making that very very clear but the
National Firearms Act of 1930 before
is very much if not the only reason
again I want to defer a little bit to
possibility it is a huge part of the
reason why fully automatic machine guns
are not legal and it's because of how
they are classified and it goes back to
the National Firearms Act of 1934
and other elements of law there have
been votes in the House of
Representatives as to whether to ban
semi-automatic weapons as well but these
votes have not succeeded at a time when
you could also get a vote to succeed in
the Senate and have it signed by the
president this is absolutely something
that could be done as this viewer points
out it wouldn't violate the Second
Amendment now it's just a matter of
where we draw the line do we we most
people agree that shoulder mounted RPGs
are on the band side and should be not
not they agree they are they agree they
should be on the ban side we have the
National Firearms Act of 1934 when it
comes to fully automatic machine guns
just a matter of where we draw the line
the the answer for why semi-automatic
weapons aren't banned is that they there
is not the political will to actually do
it it's that simple
um and I don't know maybe it will change
but you're absolutely correct that a
disproportionate number of these major
mass shootings are committed at the
hands of such a semi-automatic weapon so
Scott commented on YouTube says David
I've been watching on your uh been
watching your content for a couple of
years love what you do love your
presentation style and the way you do
you think about things you help me to
craft my own ideas about how to engage
with my trumpster dad and still allow
room for Grace knowing he has been
brainwashed by Fox that's sad I hope you
weather this storm I'm in Georgia I'm a
retired 20-year U.S Army infantry senior
NCO I am a combat veteran of Iraq and
Afghanistan I don't really know if it's
even possible or helpful but if there's
anything I can do to provide for you and
your loved ones protection and safety I
would do it for free
well I might ask for a dry place to
sleep and food if it's too far from home
thank you sir and thank you for your
service and we are weathering the storm
you know it is upsetting to many of the
in in the hate mob I know they're
Furious because they keep writing to me
they really thought they were going to
get me canceled over the tweet from now
a couple weeks ago they really did
and they saw that we came out of it with
tens of thousands more YouTube
subscribers and the website generated
over a thousand new paid subscribers and
messages of support from celebrities and
elected officials and listen anyone with
half a brain knows what I'm talking
about anyone with half a brain knows I'm
not going to blame kids who were killed
for being killed we blame our elected
officials and we blame the shooters
that's who we blame
um and aspects of the society that have
gone wrong but I really appreciate that
and we are getting through it and it's
been crazy but we are doing what we can
jack commented on YouTube and said I
used to be a conservative I switched
because of people like Pac-Man and Kyle
kolinsky keep doing what you're doing
right now David they only hate the Tweet
because you are 100 correct
conservatives are more angry over your
Tweet than they are that kids were
murdered it's a useful distraction if
you're mad at me and some of them still
are if you're mad at me
you don't have to talk about the fact
that you don't want to do a damn thing
about guns one other message along these
lines this one's from Scott this one
might be fake it's funny though it might
be real I used to be a conservative for
over 40 years Pac-Man changed that Trump
changed that I put in the paperwork to
become a Democrat and I've never been
happier I even lost weight hanging
around left Wingers you know this may be
a joke I genuinely don't know what's so
funny about it is obesity is
dramatically higher in red States I mean
we it's not about make everything
political there was recently a study
about life expectancy at Birth in the
deep blue areas of the country and the
Deep Red areas of the country obviously
you have to take economics into account
big big part of this but you are likely
to live much longer
if you are born and live in blue areas
it's
it is an incredible thing that we have
going on in this country where political
allegiance and the allegiance of state
government has such an impact on every
aspect of our lives really incredible
stuff Raymond emailed me
and said just to comment from an average
Joe I think this is super interesting
and also very depressing Raymond said
was just watching Friday feedback and
heard your advice about debating people
online I'm pretty good at it probably
because I'm 64. I've been a politics
junkie since age 16 used to skip school
so I could stay home and watch the
Watergate hearings in the last two years
I've debated at least 40 magas into
silence I set traps for them by writing
things I know they'll agree with and
then pointing out how the sum of those
beliefs add up to the opposite of the
point they're trying to make then they
go quiet they'll never admit it and
they'll never admit I'm right in the
moment but their silence signals their
capitulation but then it occurred to me
there are 70 million more of them out
there and suddenly those victories feel
pretty Hollow it's demoralizing this one
hits guys this one hits as I've said
before
we can spend hours trying to show these
people the errors in their ways
and sometimes we'll succeed
and then you remember 70 million people
voted for Trump and you realize what we
are up against so an inspiring message
from Raymond in the sense that he he has
clearly figured out a way to do it
but then you remember there's 70 million
of them and then then what then where do
we go this is the whole retail versus
wholesale strategy thing that's often
discussed the ways to achieve rapid
social change often are to enforce them
via dictatorship which I'm against I
know Trump's enamored with all these
dictators but I'm not
so then you say well then how do you do
it and it is very slow change over long
periods of time focusing on education
focusing on media literacy
extremely extremely difficult to do
Daniel wrote in and says I'm evil this
is still like the sort of stuff that's
coming in based on the tweet from a
couple weeks ago Daniel says David you
are evil I saw the Tweet you mocked
murdered Christian children I am sorry
for you your parents failed and you were
troubled on the inside May somehow you
find peace your hatred must be a serious
burden yeah no that's not really it I am
disgusted by our elected officials who
send thoughts and prayers and do nothing
else that's basically it it's not about
evil it's not about troubled it's not
about finding peace it's not about any
of it but uh these folks won't stop guys
they they keep emailing
here's George all right this is
something I think you guys are going to
enjoy
George Rhoden and said David considering
how small the trans population is
worldwide why do you spend so much time
covering trans issues please tell me how
to cancel my membership thank you George
um I've told you guys before about what
I call unsubscribe trolls these are
people who write to me and they say
David
I was just about to become a paid member
and then you said X and now I'm not
going to David I've been a subscriber
for five years but now that you said why
I'm canceling I looked up George George
was last a member in 2020.
and since 2020 this is why why we file
all of our messages sometimes law
enforcement needs them but this is
another reason why since 2020 George has
written to me
16 times
saying he's going to cancel his
membership because I said X and then
because I said why and then because I
said Z in fact when I look this up
it's like who has time to do this stuff
George wrote To Me
uh back in November
and said you're not talking about the
CCP enough
I'm canceling and then George wrote to
me in this so there's so many of these
it's hard to find all of them
uh oh God when was this George wrote to
me in May
and said they need to do something about
smart fencing at schools and you're not
talking about it and I'm going to cancel
okay the point here is
George has written to me 16 times saying
he's going to cancel
since he was last a member folks I've
said it before and I'll say it again the
freedom that I get
from being supported by individual
members is that no one person can come
in and tell me cover this or don't cover
it or whatever the case may be that's a
great thing and I will continue covering
what I think makes sense why am I
covering the trans issue more than the
prevalence of trans people in the
population very good question the reason
is because the American right wing has
now started devoting way too much of
their time to making the lives of trans
people a living hell and so when I see a
group being targeted
unfairly I come to their defense as soon
as the mob leaves trans people alone I
will be able to move away from that
issue so that's why George all right my
friend best of luck with all of it send
in your emails info davidpackman.com
YouTube comment tweet Facebook we pull
these from all over the place and uh
yours might be featured next week
fantastic bonus show for you today sign
up at joinpakman.com don't miss it
extraordinary stuff